we are in uh it's it's an Exhibition
Center and if you take a look it is
packed with people uh children families
sleeping wherever they can there are
three holes here uh it is packed they
are telling us that there is enough age
who are asking me there are deliveries
of water bread further down we can't
really show you because of the light
contrast boots are being handed out and
there is a cue of people so it does
stretch all around to the other side but
it is very difficult it becomes very
cold at night I'm gonna bring in um knee
hat who is from gaziantep uh he has been
here for the last three days nihad thank
you for talking to us tell us a little
bit about what it is like for you here
yeah it's kind of difficult to everyone
everyone
first of all I think you the channel Al
Jazeera English to show how desperate
people here
we lost our homes with us our neighbors
and it's it's very it's very difficult
it's very difficult this is the reality
it's going to be very difficult moving
forward because a lot of homes have been
destroyed if they haven't been destroyed
the infrastructure
um is broken there's danger of multiple
many many buildings collapsing so you
know we're now focusing on the rescue
and Recovery efforts but this is what
the long-term problem is tens and tens
and tens of thousands of people homeless
they're going to need shelter they're
going to need food and water and we're
just giving you a very small snapshot
here in gaziano and of course this is
something that's a reality all across
the region